well we had so much fun the first time
for some reason we're going to dive back
in to uh tick tock where we always find
all the all the most intelligent and uh
coherent and
thoughtful
advice and insights
was that out loud we're gonna have round
two of dating advice from tick tock
let's go how to make someone obsessed
with you okay listen what i'm about to
share is very manipulative and i don't
recommend you use it on just anyone but
if you want to know how then watch till
the end a lot of people think that if
you want someone to be obsessed you need
to play hard to get or ignore them and
that is false what you actually need to
do is send mixed signals because think
about it whenever someone has sent you
mixed signals that's when you've started
to psychoanalyze and figure out what
went wrong and that is when you get
hooked so how do you send mixed signals
easy you're going to create pleasure and
pain let's start with pleasure give this
person attention give them hope let them
get comfortable almost like they're in
an ocean with unlimited supplies of
water next up pain you're gonna take
them from that ocean and drop them in
the desert okay no more water supply in
other words no contact because that's
when they're gonna get confused and
that's when they're gonna worry that
they lost you the less certain they are
the more obsessed they'll become
my god i'm so glad i'm not single
i am so glad
thank you god
thank you jesus by the way um if you're
in an ocean you do not have an unlimited
supply of water because that oceans are
uh are salt water and you can't drink
that'll actually kill you faster a lot
faster than drinking nothing at all
don't you know the poem water water
everywhere so let's all have a drink
so don't drink the water in the ocean uh
in fact being stuck in an ocean it's
it's the same as being stuck in the
desert as far as the water is concerned
you're better off in the desert there's
a better chance of finding fresh water
anyway um now
she's right
that some people become more obsessive
if you manipulate them and send mixed
signals and you act all
passive-aggressive and you just treat
them generally as garbage because you
yourself are garbage you trash brock
it's true that this this can work to
keep certain kinds of people wrapped
around your finger
and um those are going to be
the passive desperate pathetic sorts of
people confident and well-adjusted
people
will get tired of your [ __ ] real
quick and they're going to leave you in
the dust where you belong so that's that
is the caveat to this advice that she
gives aside for the fact that it's
soulless and it means that you don't
care at all about the other person and
it's selfish and it's self-centered it's
all about you and you're getting some
kind of sick
perverse joy out of manipulating them
leaving all that aside
the kinds of um
people you're attracting are those kinds
of people
the high quality people are they're
gonna have no time for this whatsoever
so this is just it's a great way
to be a terrible human being
and attract all of the absolute worst
sorts of people stop ignoring me
ignoring you if that's what you're
looking for then
follow that advice
or maybe just go to the ocean and drink
all the salt water put yourself in the
world out of
our misery um okay next one hey i am a
professional dating coach and today i am
going to teach you a little body
language secret that people do when they
find you attractive so when somebody
finds you attractive what you will find
is they will itch the back of their hand
very lightly like this or scratch their
collarbone
and the reason they do this is because
it is basically inviting you to groom
them obviously this is on a subconscious
level because we don't want people to go
around grooming us however because it is
evolutionary grooming builds social
bonds and that person wants to build
social bonds with you because they find
you attractive
so if you're talking to somebody and
they start doing this around you it's
because they find you attractive
okay we finally hear from a man
that's the good news bad news is that
he's full of crap um if someone finds
you attractive they'll itch their hand
because they want you to groom them i've
never wanted to be groomed by by anybody
first of all that's the first thing
but he says that that means that they
they want they're attracted to
yeah or maybe they just have a mosquito
bite
maybe they have eczema
so this is the way we boil it down if
someone is itching themselves in your
presence they're either madly in love
with you or they have a skin condition
either that this is just total absolute
nonsense and it's going to create some
real awkward situations i mean what if
somebody hears this takes it into heart
and then and then um they see someone
scratching their hands at like
thanksgiving dinner with their family
you're gonna end up making some really
horrible and unfair assumptions about
your grandmother neck and grandma
there's too much nonsense here so we're
gonna watch one more and hope we get
something i don't know just something
coherent something that makes sense
something that is not
that is not total nonsense at least
let's let's try one more so you are
saying marriage is true humans promising
each other to be together forever yeah
you don't have romantic relationships on
your planet of course we do but we don't
promise each other to be together in the
future oh yeah wait why well we know
that the connection to each other is
based on our current energetical state
and it is a law in the universe that
energy is always shifting and moving so
no one knows if our
so you guys don't have long-term
relationships sometimes we do when the
energy of both parties grows in the same
direction my last relationship lasted
for centuries and we just parted ways
her name was al salsa so you tell me
that you're not sad that al salsa is not
your alien girlfriend anymore
funny humans again of course not the
universe is based on abundance and as
long as we're following our joy the
universe will bring someone who's more
aligned with us
marriage might have been invented so
humans feel safe forever
why does the alien sound like
christopher walken i don't know it was
the only thing i could think that entire
time
i'm not sure if i need to respond in
point by point detail to that because
i'm not exactly sure what that was or
what was happening there or why
the alien's name was salsa or any
there's a lot of questions and in spite
of all of that
somehow i think that was the most
coherent thing we've seen today always
look on the bright side of life